The next time you eat a giant hamburger, don't
do it like this. The bottoms get soggy and
fall apart. Instead, try turning your sandwich
upside down. The tops are nearly twice as
thick as the bottoms, and a lot more durable.
So be smart, and eat your hamburgers upside
down.
Have you ever noticed that when you put a
straw in a can of soda, it doesn't want to
stay? Try bending the tab of the can over
the hole and slide your straw down through
the tab. No more floating straws, because
now, it's held in place.
Grab yourself a mango and try this little
trick. Carefully cut off the two sides of
the fruit, and hold one piece in your hand.
You can gently cut a few lines vertically,
and a few more across, until the pattern resembles
a checkerboard. Now take it with both hands
and gently push from the back. You'll see
bite sized pieces pop right up.
You can use a spoon to scrape
them into a bowl, or just eat them right off
the peel. It's fast, easy, and they won't
get stuck in your teeth.
If you've got ants and you're looking for
a natural form of pest control, try measuring
out a cup of popcorn kernels. Put them in
a blender, on high speed for about 30 seconds,
and you'll end up with a batch of fresh, homemade
cornmeal. Just make a few piles around the
ant trails and within a few days, your ant
problems will, literally disappear.
The next time you're at a party and someone
has bags of chips laying around, impress your
friends by making them into custom snack bowls.
You can fold the top edge inside the bag first,
then begin rolling the bottom corners, up
into the base of the bag, pushing the chips
up as you go. You'll end up with a custom
snack bowl, with chips overflowing.
It's the season for fruit flies, so before
they take over your kitchen, slice a few pieces
of banana and mix them with some of your leftover
mango peels. Find yourself a couple of small
containers, and add the fruit. Now just stretch
a piece of plastic wrap over the top, and
use something like the tip of a chopstick
to poke a small hole in the center that's
just bigger than the fly. Now you can set
it and forget it. Within a few minutes, the
flies will be checking things out, and once
one goes in, you can be sure his friends will
follow. Within a couple of days, they'll all
be having a rocking fruit party. And now you
can simply, take the lid of the container
and press it on, sealing them inside. Now
you, are the lord of the flies.
Summer means popsicles, and popsicles mean
your kids are going to get sticky fingers.
Grab a small paper cup, and carefully poke
a hole in the bottom, about the size of a
popsicle stick. Now when you push a popsicle
inside, you've got an instant drip catcher,
and no more sticky fingers. By the way, this
works great with cupcake liners as well!
You've probably been to a BBQ where the condiments
take up half the table, and the lineups for
using them take forever. Solve the problem
with a muffin pan. This way your condiments
are easy to access and your lines will move
along quickly. You'll also dramatically increase
your table space, and cut down the things
to clean up afterward.
When you're at the beach, reduce the chances
of things getting stolen by making a covert
container. Just take your old shampoo bottle
and twist the top so that it pops right off.
Clean it out and cut a hole in the top that's
just big enough, to stash your valuable items
inside. Now you can snap the top back on,
and your items are perfectly concealed. Anyone
who sees this will just think it's a shampoo
bottle, and chances are, nobody's wants to
steal your shampoo.
When you need a drink to cool down, hot water
can taste disgusting. Try filling your water
bottles, a quarter of the way, so that when
their on their sides, the water settles just
below the bottle neck. Now stick your bottles
in the freezer and go on with your day. When
the water is frozen it will make an ice block
on the side the bottle, but doesn't block
the opening. Now when you need to cool off
just take a bottle from the freezer, fill
it up with your favorite drink, and you've
got an instant, icy cold beverage ready to
go.
Well there are a few tricks, to make your
summer, a littler easier. If you liked these
projects, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com